instead c'est toujours une ronde de voir
encore une poignée de personnes autour
de nous ou parmi nous d'ailleurs
rwandais au rwanda
il reste les bras croisés
agissez aujourd'hui où il sera peut-être
trop tard rythme arbitres ou light non
seulement pour l'ukraine les fraudes
mais pour vous tous made for lovin
nous appelons au plein respect de la
convention sur la sûreté nucléaire et
des autres conventions pertinentes la
france réitère enfin son soutien
indéfectible à l'indépendance à la
souveraineté et à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine dans ses
frontières internationalement reconnues
la réunion d'aujourd'hui est une
tentative de plus des autorités de kiev
de raviver une hystérie artificiel à
propos de ce qui se passe en ukraine et
ils sont encouragés par des bailleurs
occidentaux
aujourd'hui nous avons une fois de plus
entendu des mensonges sur la façon dont
les fruits sont attaqué la centrale
nucléaire